let's say that we have the function
capital f of x which we're going to
define as the definite integral from 1
to sine of x so that's an interesting
upper bound right over there
of 2t minus 1 and of course dt
and what we are curious about is trying
to figure out what is
f prime of x going to be equal to so
pause this video and see if you can
figure that out
all right
so some of you might have been a little
bit challenged by this notion of hey
instead of an x on this upper bound i
now have a sine of x if it was just an x
i could have used the fundamental
theorem of calculus just to review that
if i had a function let me call it h of
x
if i have h of x that was defined as the
definite integral from 1 to x
of 2t minus 1
dt
we know from the fundamental theorem of
calculus that h prime of x would be
simply this inner function with the t
replaced by the x it would just be two x
minus one pretty straightforward but
this one isn't quite as straightforward
instead of having an x up here our upper
bound is a sine of x so one way to think
about it is
if we were to define g of x
as being equal to
sine of x
equal to sine of x our capital f of x
can be expressed as
capital f of x
is the same thing as h of
h of
instead of an x everywhere we see an x
we're replacing it with a sine of x so
it's h of
g of x
g of x you can see the g of x
right over there so you replace x with g
of x for where in this expression you
get h of g of x and that is capital f of
x now why am i doing all of that
well this might start making you think
about the chain rule because if this is
true then that means that capital f
prime of x is going to be equal to
h prime
of g of x
h prime of g of x
times g prime of x
and so what would that be well we
already know what h prime of x is so
let me do this in another color this
part right over here is going to be
equal to
everywhere we see an x here we'll
replace with the g of x so it's going to
be
2
2 times sine of x
2 sine
of x and then minus 1
minus 1.
this
is this right over here and then what's
g prime of x
g prime of x well g prime
of x is just of course the derivative of
sine of x is cosine of x
is cosine of x so this part right over
here is going to be
cosine of x and we could keep going we
could try to
we could try to simplify this a little
bit or rewrite it in different ways but
there you have it